your highness  you belong to India not here acting a  part of a noble foreigner I have wasted  enough time indulging in this firm so I  could see you now I always recommend  bringing someone's mother into the  argument how may we help his Highnesses  our troubles with the British Indies  company we must return this goal to its  people my people  there's someone intruding on our affairs  find them and kill them need to find out  why the temples in the British in these  companies have joined forces what we  should do is track them down and destroy  their headquarters that may not be such  a terrible idea mr. fry  you'll never be more than a trophy of  war it seems you have learned nothing of  India there is no way a knife Jack we  can fix you fix me I  you